okay so here's what's been coming up for
me today it may seem like an obvious
platitude but that doesn't make it any
less
important we are the sum
of our experiences right we become
what we behold and so from this we can
gather of course that our
choices matter that there are real
consequences to our actions for what we
choose
we become our creative and linguistic
choices govern our fate i design
therefore i become
clearly i've talked about this before
the whole
notion of why design
matters gets to the heart of the matter
for what we design
designs us
ourselves it has been written in
epigenetics
are a technology that literally turns
experience into
biology kind of like an ontological
tattoo
our experiences are written on our face
they're tattooed on
our bodies which tells us of course that
we have again
agency over who we become
we have authorship over our future self
every
moment is rendering who we become in the
next
moment
david lenson famously wrote that
consciousness is a collaboration
between subject and object right
so consciousness is a kind of like an
equation it's person
right multiplied by place and context
multiplied
by time which gives us a kind of guard
in the four key paths of possible
consciousness
of possible selves of possible people
that you could
be they tell us also that we are the sum
of the people we spend the most amount
of time with how
obvious is this we become our friends we
become our
lovers we see ourselves reflected in how
they see us
i am not who i think i am i am not who
you think i am
i am who i think you think i am so there
are this
there are these loops these feedback
loops this constant
mirroring between us and our context
us and the places we dwell us and the
people we encounter
us and the words we use us and the
places we go
[Music]
and so why does this matter
well it matters because we want our
lives to stand for something it matters
because
meaning matters it matters because we're
standing
on a rock an upright ape naked and
trembling
before the cosmos it matters because in
the face of the ineffable of the
infinite of the
unquantifiable of the vast of space
and time on a scale just shy of the
infinite we have
the opportunity to do something
meaningful to make of our lives
a living breathing work of art because
life exists inside of these individual
moments and it is up to us
to make sure those moments are vital and
interconnected and grand and to make of
our
lives a masterful work of art a dynamic
work of art one that we would willingly
live again and again
for all of eternity this is what we can
strive for
this can be our compass this can be our
north star this can be the reason we get
out of bed
in the morning we can strive
for excellence we can strive for
adventure we can strive
for experience
[Music]
this and more is what we can strive for
i'll leave you with that
may you choose wisely